i had a real issue with society saying i
should be
friends with my exes and i noticed that
they called me a lot to be the emotional
tampon and i finally told them look lose
my number
done go away and not a single one of
them that i told
to lose my number none of them reacted
well i got hung up
on by one of them the other one started
yelling i hung up on her
the other one just immediately started
crying and i'm like no i'm done
bye i'll give you one of the best sound
bites you can use with x's
this works especially well with ex-wives
the wi-fi router's not working what do i
do seamus
i don't work for you anymore they seem
to have these expectations that
yeah that you're that useful idiot you
know that's that's that's always going
to be available to them to solve their
problems women have been sold this lie
their entire life that they're
that they're extremely valuable and men
should bend the knee to them and all
this sort of stuff and i
you know i continue to teach you guys to
set some boundaries and be firm with
them and
why you should and how it serves you
better and it actually serves your
relationships better too